David, do you think it's a problem that people
are making huge amounts of money from the
development and manufacture of coronavirus
vaccines?
Listen, I think that my view on this will
probably anger most people other than like
Social Democrats that are exactly in my political
space.
I think there has to be a middle ground on
this.
Now, on
the one hand,
we, as Bernie Sanders recently said, we can't
allow these pharmaceutical companies to hold
governments and and humans hostage when it
comes to something like health.
As I've said before, demand for health care
services and medications and vaccines is inelastic.
What I mean by that is my appendectomy right
up until the day at which my appendix swelled
and became painful.
I don't care what the price is for appendectomies.
I don't want one.
I don't need one.
And then all of a sudden when I require an
emergency appendectomy,
they
have me over a barrel.
I need and and I must find a way to pay any
price for an appendectomy because health care
services and demand is is completely inelastic.
So we need health is what we would call a
special.
It can't just be left to the free market now,
on the other hand, as I've said before, as
a social Democrat,
I don't
need I'm fine with the market dictating what
video game consoles get made and who makes
them and what they charge.
I'm OK with that.
I'm fine with that.
Mobile phones.
I'm OK.
You know, I don't need the government involved
in regulating mobile phone prices.
I think that the market and that is a consumer
product.
It's I'm fine with that, assuming that everybody's
playing within a regulatory framework and
to some degree, the the smartest, best people
we have are going to be more likely to line
up to do things like developing a vaccine
for the virus quickly if there is something
there for them.
Now, many people will point to Russia and
say, well, look at Russia.
Russia developed the Sputnik vaccine basically
as quickly as the Moderna and Pfizer vaccines
were developed.
And because they did, they didn't even finish
testing it.
They they started using it even more quickly.
If you understand the authoritarian nature
of Russia, you would realize that although
it did happen essentially as quickly as Pfizer
and Moderna, which which we will talk about,
it wasn't just because out of the the goodwill
and desire it took place.
You're talking about an authoritarian situation
there, as we've been talking about for decades
at this point in time.
So, I mean, listen, the Turkish couple in
Germany that developed
what is now called the Pfizer vaccine, they
are now very wealthy.
They invested time and money in developing
that vaccine.
And now there is a payoff.
If there was absolutely no payoff, then would
they do it again?
I mean, maybe not.
And you look at Pfizer, Pfizer increased revenue
two percent after investing billions of dollars
in R&D and production on this vaccine.
Is that bad?
I mean, two percent?
Yeah, it's a huge company.
It's a huge amount of money.
You could apply the same logic to researchers
of other vaccines.
Don't we want people entering the field of
science and developing things that can be
lifesaving?
Of course, we need to ensure access.
Of course, we need situations where things
are subsidized.
Of course, Bernie is right when he says, you
know, the patenting of these vaccines, when
it comes to them being produced in other countries,
we need to take control of this.
We can't do it in a way where other countries
are prevented from making the vaccine.
Of course, we need to do all of those things.
But at the same time, we want to incentivize
people to get into these fields.
If the belief is the way you make a lot of
money is by, you know, I don't know, becoming
a celebrity or an athlete or a,
you know,
high priced lawyer or a consultant or whatever,
and then people don't get into these fields
of medical research that we're all worse off.
So I believe there has to be a middle ground.
Maybe the government needs to be involved
in determining what are fair prices.
You know, all of these things have caveats,
but context is crucial.
And when you say should it be possible for
pharmaceutical companies to hold the world
hostage, charging three hundred dollars per
vaccine dose?
No, no, that shouldn't be possible.
Should it be OK for people that are developing
lifesaving technologies to be rewarded in
a way that's commensurate with what they are
doing?
Yeah, to some degree that should be OK.
And you know what?
If they make a ton of money, they should pay
a lot of taxes.
And all of the other economic policy that
we and Bernie and others have been talking
about, I think context is key and there has
to be a middle path here.
And I'm curious to hear from you where you
fall on this issue, make sure you are a member
at join Pakman Dotcom to
get access to
the bonus show.
Otherwise, I'll see you on Monday.